mathematik ist die sprache des
universums das wird zumindest immer
wieder behauptet egal wo man hinblickt
oder wo man sich befindet mit mathe kann
man die natur beschreiben
und obwohl wir vielleicht in einem
universum leben in dem es so etwas wie
den zufall gar nicht geben könnte können
uns wahrscheinlichkeiten eine menge
verraten wie dieses gedankenexperiment
zeigt
stellt euch vor wir reisen mit einem
portal in eine andere dimension nennen
wie sie dimensionen c 1 37 wir wissen
nichts über diesen alternativen zeit
standen unserer welt also beginnen die
diese welt zu erkunden
wir stoßen auf einen computer also kann
sich dieses universum nicht allzu sehr
von unserem unterscheiden immerhin muss
es mikrochips elektrizität und tausend
andere dinge dafür geben wir öffnen
wikipedia also gibt es auch das internet
und wikipedia selbst und klicken auf
zufälliger artikel um zu sehen was
dieses universum noch zu bieten hat
wir landen auf der seite zum siebzehnten
star wars film ok also gibt es hier
schon ein paar mehr als in unserem
universum aber jetzt wird's interessant
gibt es eine möglichkeit nur anhand
dieser zahl 17 herauszufinden wie viele
star wars filme in dieser dimension
insgesamt gedreht wurden
das ist das german tank problem oder auf
deutsch dass deutsche panzer problem
denn während des zweiten weltkriegs sind
die alliierten auf ein ganz ähnliches
problem gestoßen
sie wollten wissen wie viele deutsche
panzer jeden monat produziert werden die
einzige informationsquelle die sie
hatten waren die nummerierten deutschen
panzer die immer mal wieder gesichtet
wurden und überraschender weise bieten
einen komplett zufällige zahlen sehr
viele informationen findet man zum
beispiel einen panzer mit der nummer 217
kann man daraus direkt zwei dinge
schließen
zum einen dass es insgesamt mindestens
217 panzer geben muss vorausgesetzt dass
die panzer fortlaufend durchnummeriert
werden und zum anderen kann man allein
von dieser zahl ausgehend erste
schätzungen über die maximale anzahl der
panzer machen
zum beispiel ist es extrem
unwahrscheinlich dass jeden monat
mehrere millionen panzer produziert
werden
die chance dass wir bei diesen zahlen
einen dreistelligen operierten panzer
finden ist sehr unwahrscheinlich
okay dass die deutschen nicht millionen
panzer herstellen hätte man sich
wahrscheinlich auch so denken können
aber man kann jetzt schon eine
wahrscheinlichkeit verteilung aufstellen
und zwar mit der einfachen formel 1
durch xviii ihr sehen könnt ist es am
wahrscheinlichsten dass es 217 panzer
gibt möchte man aber möglichst nah am
durchschnitt sein sollte man seine zeit
verdoppeln
das ergibt auch sinn wenn man nur eine
einzige zeit kennt und einem alles
andere unbekannt ist man ist einfach an
das man sich exakt in der mitte befindet
und verdoppelt um auf den maximalen wert
zu kommen
aber jetzt wird wirklich cool denn wir
bekommen mehr informationen ein zweiter
deutscher panzer wurde gesichtet und er
hatte die nummer 91
auf den ersten blick ändern sich durch
diese neue information nichts denn
unsere minimale anzahl panzer ist
weiterhin 217 aber 91 ist in einem
ähnlichen bereich wie unsere erste zahl
und untermauert weiter unsere vermutung
dass die anzahl der produzierten panzer
in den hunderten und nicht in den
tausenden oder sogar noch darüber liegt
wir können diese beiden informationen
jetzt miteinander multiplizieren und
erhalten hier in roth unsere erneuerte
wahrscheinlichkeit für die maximale
anzahl der produzierten panzer am
wahrscheinlichsten ist immer noch dass
es insgesamt 217 panzer gibt aber die
neue information hat die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass die maximale
anzahl in den hohen 100 liegt stark nach
unten gedrückt
je mehr informationen wir bekommen 256
248 61 desto genauer wird unsere
wahrscheinlichkeit verteilung bis wir
uns irgendwann sehr sicher sein können
dass die anzahl der produzierten panzer
irgendwo zwischen 256 und 300 liegt und
so war es auch nach ende des krieges
konnten die alliierten ihre berechnungen
mit den aufzeichnungen der nazis
vergleichen und sehen dass die
wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung fast schon
beängstigend genau war und das im
vergleich zu schätzungen vieler experten
die sich nie eigentlich waren
ob die deutschen nun 100 oder 1000
panzer produzieren würden
und seitdem benutzen die wenigsten
staaten oder unternehmen noch
fortlaufende seriennummern für
irgendetwas das auch nur halbwegs geheim
ist vor einigen jahren benutzte apple
noch einmal fortlaufende nur mal für
ihre iphones und mit nur 40
seriennummern konnte einen blogger die
insgesamt verkaufte anzahl der telefone
fast exakt berechnen und das alles durch
die kraft des zufalls der durch seine
unberechenbarkeit berechenbar wird
paradox eigentlich aber es ist nicht das
einzige paradoxon in der
wahrscheinlichkeit das ist die gaußsche
normalverteilung die viele von uns aus
der schule kennen dürften diese kurve
tritt sehr häufig auf wenn um einen
vorgang herum zufälle in beide
richtungen auftreten zum beispiel bei
einer klassenarbeit bei der
massenproduktion von gegenständen oder
wenn dinge ausgemessen werden und was
hier rot eingezeichnet ist ist die
standardabweichung das sind die 68
prozent der fälle die am nächsten am
mittelwert liegen
das heißt wenn ich zum beispiel zu den
68 der menschen gehören die um den
mittelwert von sagen wir einmal
körpergröße liegen bei männern
78 dann bin ich mathematisch betrachtet
normal
die spanne umfasst hier ungefähr 5 cm in
jede richtung bedeutet da sich zwischen
1 meter 73 und ein meter 83 groß sein
muss um normal groß zu sein
für frauen sind das übrigens 1 meter 60
bis 70 aber ich finde es problematisch
diese aussage der normalität auf
menschen anzuwenden denn statistisch
betrachtet habe ich gerade einem drittel
von euch gesagt dass ihr normal groß
oder klein sein aber lasst mich das
korrigieren wir sind alle unnormal
jeder von uns und ich kann es sogar
mathematisch beweisen wie der physiker
theodore modus beschrieben hat braucht
es nur 36 kategorien die einen menschen
beschreiben
zum beispiel wie groß er ist wie viele
freunde hat wie schneller laufen kann
und so weiter die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass man in allen 36 kategorien normal
ist ist eins zu einer million
und ich kann mir ohne mühe 100
kategorien ausdenken die menschen
beschreiben
es ist also mathematisch gesehen
vollkommen unnormal normal zu sein
paradox aber viele wissenschaftliche
studien deuten auch darauf hin dass
besonders seien besser ist als normal
sein auch wenn das bedeutet dass man von
vielen eher abgelehnt wird
auch das klingt paradox aber lasst es
mich kurz erklären
stellt euch eine online dating seite vor
durch das hohe angebot an potenziellen
partnern ist man leicht überfordert jede
einzelne option in erwägung zu ziehen
im umkehrschluss bedeutet das fürs
eigene profil dass man seine
ungewöhnlichen und vielleicht sogar
seine oft ungeliebten merkmale
herausstellen sollte
klar verringert man die anzahl der
interessenten damit erstmal denn nur die
wenigsten leute wären gerne mit jemandem
zusammen der sagen wir mal spinnen als
haustiere hält aber diejenigen die so
etwas besonders interessant finden sehen
sofort dass es sich hier um ein spinnen
liebhaber handelt und so geht man für
diese wenigen wichtigen menschen nicht
in der masse unter okay vielleicht habt
ihr keine spinnen als haustiere aber das
prinzip lässt sich eigentlich auf alles
anwenden wo wir von der norm ab was
macht euch besonders seid ihr der
allergrößte star wars fan auf der welt
spielt professionell triangel oder seit
hobby botaniker stellt diese
besonderheiten in den vordergrund auch
wenn es unlogisch wird wenn er ehrlich
sein findet ihr viel schneller die
menschen mit denen hier wirklich etwas
anfangen können
aber passt auf mit welchen worten ihr
euch beschreibt denn ihr könntet aus
versehen ein weiteres paradox von
kreieren auto logische wörter sind
wörter die sich selber beschreiben 73
ist zum beispiel ein dreiseitiges wort
klein geschrieben wird klein geschrieben
und 18 buchstabe hat 18 buchstaben
meteorologische wörter hingegen
beschreiben nicht sich selbst englisch
mit sch ist leider nicht englisch
sondern deutsch
neu ist kein neues wort denn man benutzt
schon seit jahrhunderten und
umgangssprachlich ist alles andere als
länger sondern reines hochdeutsch aber
was für ein wort ist theologisch
meteorologisch ist ein paradoxon egal
wie man es versucht einzuordnen wenn man
davon ausgeht dass es ein
meteorologisches wort ist sich also
nicht selber beschreiben würde dann
müsste es auto logisch sein um seiner
definition zu entsprechen
geht man aber davon aus dass das auto
logisch ist sich also selber beschreibt
dann ist die definition von hetero-
logisch aber dass er sich eben nicht
selber beschreiben paradoxon der nächste
satz ist eine lüge
der letzte satz war die wahrheit kann
ein allmächtiger gott einen stein
erschaffen den er nicht selber heben
kann
und könnt ihr den like -button drücken
neben jetzt also könnt ihr ihn wirklich
drücken um das zu tun müsste sich eure
hand zum button bewegen aber um das zu
schaffen müsste sie erst mal die hälfte
der strecke zurücklegen wenn ihr das
geschafft habt müsst ihr wieder die
hälfte der strecke zurücklegen und
danach wieder die hälfte davon
ihr müsst eine unendliche anzahl von
schritten erledigen könnt ihr es also
jemals schaffen schreibt mir eure
liebsten paradox da unten in die
comments ansonsten bin ich weg herein